[Música]
[Aplausos]
qué tal buenas tardes yo soy non caron
soy un artista plástico
soy mejor conocido en la industria por
crear un tipo de arte que se llama arte
aumentado
y esto consiste en utilizar una
tecnología
e influencia militar aumentada y se
desarrolló la tecnología hasta donde yo
tengo entendido en los años 80 con el
propósito de utilizarse para mandar
mensajes encriptados obviamente en
mensajes secretos y luego en los 90s en
el año 2000 se empezó a popularizar un
poco en otras industrias como la de
mobiliaria sin comunicación marketing en
fin un sinfín de
de distintas industrias yo fui pionero
en el 2013 en incorporarlo para el arte
y lo que trataba de hacer era darle la
oportunidad a la gente de ver el cuadro
con una especie de alma que vieran que
vieran el cuadro con los ojos con los
que yo miro las cosas cuando yo veo una
obra estética quieta yo me imagino una
historia algo que estoy contando y
cuando empecé a hacer esto era
justamente lo que quería que la demás
gente pudiera ver
en general yo no soy un conferencista
les les pido una disculpa pero puede
hacer un gran esfuerzo y yo creo que
simplemente el hecho de ser artista
es una celebración de la vida es una
forma de resolver los miedos y sentarse
a ellos y obviamente estar parado aquí
enfrente de ustedes para mí representa
un enfrentamiento a mis propios miedos
y bueno como les quería compartir hace
rato por ejemplo me preguntaron cuál es
tu definición del arte yo creo que el
arte es
cada quien tiene su propia definición
cada quien experimenta el arte
s
es más cada quien puede
definir el arte en diferentes
circunstancias de diferentes maneras
para mí conectar con el arte es conectar
con mi niño interno
y experimentar las cosas que de niño me
hacían feliz cuando tenía 8 años y una
película que se llamaba quién engañó a
roger rabbit no sé si ustedes acuerdan
de esa película
en el momento que yo la vi yo me
imaginaba
la posibilidad de convivir con dibujos
animados favoritos y que poder compartir
esta realidad con ellos más adelante
cuando puede desarrollar la aplicación
de realidad aumentada puede hacer desde
cierta manera eso posible y compartirlo
con las personas obviamente los retos de
convertirse en un artista son muchísimos
es una carrera que está medio satanizada
de la gente cree que la mayoría de los
artistas son vagos o problemáticos
han tenido un pasado muy oscuro
no necesariamente cierto yo creo que
para convertirse en un artista en la
verdadera obra maestra del artista es el
mismo y las obras que el artista crea
son solo un registro temporal el
performance eterno que es la vida y la
celebración de la misma